m
marseille deuxième ville de france
forte de ses 850 mille habitants un
territoire immense grand comme deux fois
et demi paris ou 5 x lion une superficie
qui justifie la présence de pas moins de
quatre cent quarante quatre écoles
primaires publiques où sont scolarisés
73 mille élèves
alors bien sûr dans la cité phocéenne
on entendait parler de conditions
d'enseignement pas toujours glorieuses
de locaux vétustes
quand des parents d'élèves se mobilisent
est ici ou des syndicats enseignants
haussé le ton la relayés par des élus ou
la presse locale
mais c'est libération qui jette un pavé
dans la mare en y consacrant sa une le 2
février 2016 école à marseille la honte
de la république un titre choc
accompagnée d'un dossier de quatre pages
sur la situation
et ce n'est qu'un début les photos
afflux compilées par des syndicats ou
des médias locaux classe à moins de 15
degrés l'hiver rongeurs dans les
couloirs locaux insalubres
sol jonché de trous ou encore sanitaire
dans un état déplorable
pas question pour la municipalité de
laisser cette idée prospérer alors le
sénateur maire jean claude gaudin contre
attaque très rapidement
il est très facile de prendre dans une
école sur 444 ou dans deux écoles ou
dans trois ce qui ne va pas et de le
mentionner d'une manière extraordinaire
encore une fois c'est très excessif par
rapport à la réalité des choses
deux ou trois écoles seulement concerner
pas vraiment le sentiment de la
sénatrice maire des 15e et 16e
arrondissements samia ghali qui dit
dénoncer la situation depuis des années
sans avoir jamais été entendu comment on
peut 2e ligue de france avoir des écoles
qui ressemble aux écoles et
malheureusement de la misère des écoles
qui est ressorti son du quart monde
voilà qui ressemble car monde mais ça
c'est pas acceptable dans la deuxième
ville de france
même une c'est une de trop habitués à
être pointés du doigt par la presse
nationale pour ses règlements de comptes
en série
la ville est cette fois accusée de
laisser certaines de ces écoles à
l'abandon pendant deux mois
nous avons enquêté sur cette polémique
si cette fois le focus nationale est
pointée sur les écoles phocéenne c'est
qu'un cri d' alerte a résonné plus fort
que les autres
un cri sous forme de lettre envoyée à la
ministre de l'éducation nationale par
une enseignante des quartiers nord de la
ville
madame la ministre je vous écris cette
lettre parce que ma colère d'enseignante
m'empêche de vivre et pire encore de
travailler marseille quartiers nord une
de ces écoles en décrépitude où les
enseignants assez souvent en état de
survie psychiques ont pris l'habitude de
trouver normal les conditions que nous
imposons à nos élèves
je nous accusent d' aggraver les
inégalités sociales je nous accuse de
produire sciemment de l'échec scolaire
et des délinquants je nous accuse de
jouer avec la santé des enfants des
classes sociales les moins favorisées
je respecte trop mes élèves et leurs
parents pour trouver cela normal
un jeu nous accuse publié sur un blog
puis repris par un site d'information
locale un texte accompagné de photos qui
marque les esprits
c'est un élève que j'ai pris en photo
alors pas dans l'école où j'étais en ce
début d'année scolaire mais une autre
école des quartiers dans laquelle je
travaillais l'année dernière donc on a
un élève en doudoune qui essaye d'écrire
avec les doigts un peu court
certaines écoles dans ces quartiers là
sans laisser à l'abandon
et encore une fois ça c'est une photo
pour n'importe quel enseignant
marseillais qui a l'habitude de
travailler dans les quartiers nord c'est
une photo que tout le monde
enfin c'est un genre de photos que tout
le monde a son téléphone portable ça n'a
rien de surprenant des situations devenu
banal qui s'accumulent jusqu'au moment
où le vase trop plein des bordes le jour
où une maman d'élève m'a demandé si
il ne valait pas mieux que sa fille
reste à la maison
les deux prochains jours en attendant
que le chauffage puisse être réparé si
on avait de la chance et que je me suis
entendu lui répondre oui effectivement
c'est mieux il vaut mieux qu'elle reste
à la maison parce qu'elle avait les
lèvres bleues en fin de journée je me
suis dit c'est pas possible
il aura fallu le relais de libération
pour que cette lettre envoyée en
novembre 2015 à najat vallaud belkacem
est enfin une réponse non la situation
n'est pas acceptable pour la ministre à
prendre le sujet des écoles marc faye
aide au sérieux avez-vous autour d'une
table et travaillons justement un
certain nombre d'écoles qui sont dans un
état de délabrement à nous faire
apportés par les parents eux mêmes qui
ne va pas qui n'est pas acceptable dans
notre république pas acceptable dans
notre république
la phrase est lâchée jean claude gaudin
est pointé du doigt comme un mauvais
élève
pas question pour lui d'accepter ce
bonnet d'âne sans broncher la réplique
aura lieu lors du conseil municipal du 8
février
dans ce théâtre où les joutes verbales
n'ont rien à envier à du pagnol le maire
lâche ses coups et joue les offusqués je
n'avais jamais vu ça et pourtant j'avais
vu un grand quotidien national qui se
livrent une manipulation des faits fric
est tronquée des formes et au mépris de
toutes les règles de la déontologie
journalistique
c'est une honte pour ce journal un
gouvernement qui se vautre immédiatement
dans l'exploitation de cette campagne de
presse sans doute excité temps des élus
toujours à vivre de publicité dans une
compétition électorale interne
gauche c'est une honte mais vos photos
que vous avez vues elles vous plaisent
pas c'est vraiment non plus à me
plaisent pas moi aussi j'ai pas envie
j'aurais préféré qu'elle ne soit pas là
mais en même temps si elles existent si
les photographes l'ont fait ces quelques
spectacles au parc ça existe je vous
propose à tous élus ou membres de la
presse d'effectuer des visites les
visites que vous voudrez dans les écoles
que vous voudrez quand vous voudrez
nous montrons ensemble dans un minibus
et vous irez voir exactement la réalité
de ce que vous prétendez dépeindre dans
certains articles et là vous comprendrez
aussitôt dit aussitôt fait les
journalistes sont invités à monter dans
le bus et même à choisir leur école avec
de faussaires de voyages scolaires
l'opération communication de la mairie
est en route
premier arrêt et surprise samia ghali
n'a pas manqué l'occasion de participer
à cette virée dans son secteur
face à elle aucun élu de la majorité
municipale mais des fonctionnaires pas
autorisées à s'exprimer
la sénatrice a tout le loisir de
torpiller l'opération communication de
la mairie les travaux de chauffage se
font pas ou que les travaux que vos
services ne font pas le boulot j'ai
juste que en matière de chauffage à des
écoles ça dure plus longtemps que
d'autres mais quand on a des vitres qui
sont cassés l'entente et du chauffage
malheureusement ça suffit pas son corps
dans le mistral et comme on a souvent du
mistral à marseille mais c'est vrai
qu'on s'approche de vrais problèmes
l'école présente bien quelques problèmes
mais tout le monde s'accorde à dire
qu'elle n'est pas la pierre le convoi
décide d'aller dans celles les plus
cités par la presse
direction l'école kallisté située dans
une des cités les plus sensibles des
quartiers nord et les parents d'élèves
sont présents pour dire tout le bien
qu'il pense de la municipalité la ville
alors oui monsieur koné c'est vraiment
la dégradation alors monsieur côté il
arrête de donner aux quartiers sud de la
ville et vient pour quartiers nord cali
c'est ça existe ping comme tout le monde
voit ressurgir monsieur wade et qu'il se
bouge un peu le trou du cul là si vous
voulez coupé vous coupez votre remballez
vos mots il y est ici et il vient voir
ce qu'il va faire via lépine jours à
faire mais des travaux à faire
il ya des tas de trucs alors vous êtes
venu puisque vous savez qu'ils avaient
des journalistes non non c'est moi ici
encore peu de problème visible parents
d'élèves et élus dénonçant le fait qu'il
s'agit de la maternelle voisine qui
accumule les problèmes et non cette
école élémentaire en pleines vacances
scolaires la mairie arguent qu'elle n'a
pas les clés les journalistes sont donc
priés de rester derrière le portail
avant de se diriger vers la dernière est
devant l'école jean perrin celle-là même
où enseigne et charlotte magri qui a
écrit à la ministre
là aussi les parents d'élèves sont
présents et des travaux ils en ont bien
vu mais juste avant la visite des
journalistes et où d'un week-end ils
sont venus faire quelques travaux et les
lannoyens oui les jeunes on habite tous
ici donc ça peut être constaté ils sont
venus ils ont fait appel à des agents de
maintenance pour venir nettoyer et faire
les petits travaux pour soi déjà on
montrait que nos écoles sont propres
mais vous allez voir la réalité monsieur
voilà le directeur des problèmes mais
surtout les problèmes
mesdames messieurs les journalistes
voilà ce que nous avons voulu faire
c'est une visite de presse la presse
peut en effet constater les différents
problèmes dans l'école comme des trous
importants au sol et des fenêtres qui ne
s'ouvre plus le dialogue entre le
représentant finalement dépêché par la
mairie et les parents d'élèves sont
venus là que vous êtes dans ces décors
ici c'est l'école de madame magri vous
pouvez c'est qu'on l'oublié mais c'est
l'école de la dame qui a fait sa lettre
il pas tout c'est quand vous avez sa
classe vous pouvez voir ce qui va ce qui
va pas dans sa classe vous pouvez vous
rendre compte par vous même et vous
pouvez voir si si vraiment l'expression
la honte de la république est fondée
vous ouvrir les écoles de marseille
voulait pas nous c'est la rolls de la
réalité j'ai des solutions
l'un de vous dire que cette visite à la
presse et le directeur général des
services a bien du mal à expliquer la
présence de nappes en papier sur les
murs des éléments sur la pédagogie
qu'est ce que vous répondez
est ce que les professeurs peuvent pas
faire la classe bien entendu tant qu'ils
sont au contraire n'est pas vrai la
peinture savoir peinture bien entendu
qu'il faut regarder
pas besoin de parler parce qu'il veut
parler donc en menant directement on est
venus pour voir monsieur donc si c'est
ça que vous l'avez a montré à la presse
ça va pas bien on alertant les parents
d'élèves samia ghali a réussi à
transformer l'exercice de communication
de la mairie en un fiasco total
l'état lui non plus n'a pas apprécié le
déni de la mairie la ministre de
l'éducation nationale et celui de la
ville ont donc saisi la préfecture et
l'inspection académique pour un réel
inventaire de la situation les deux
institutions vont travailler d'urgence
sur ce dossier pas une mise sous tutelle
mais une surveillance rapprochée pour la
mère le principe de la libre
administration des collectivités
territoriales n'est pas remise en cause
par notre travail
donc la responsabilité de des écoles
incombe bien la ville de marseille notre
mission c'est d'être aux côtés de la
mairie de marseille pour faire en sorte
que cette mission soit rempli le mieux
possible et réellement nous sommes en
appui nous sommes en a pu mais nous ne
faisons pas à la place des alertes ont
été lancées
je pense que ces alertes n'ont peut-être
pas eu suffisamment d'écho c'est ce que
l'on constate aujourd'hui que notre
attention même si elle a été grande
au titre de nos deux institutions n'a
peut-être pas été suffisamment grande
et je crois que pour reprendre les
propos que vous évoquez tout à l'heure
la lettre de d2 ministre rappelle
qu'aujourd'hui l'état doit être d'une
vigilance absolue par rapport à la
situation s'est dit prêt dans un état
des lieux officiels doit donc être fait
mais pas question pour les élus
d'attendre sans rien faire dont les 15e
et 16e arrondissements samia ghali veut
faire son propre inventaire la sénatrice
maire convoque un conseil
d'arrondissement extraordinaire sur les
écoles parents d'élèves et enseignants
de ce secteur sont appelés à témoigner
mais finalement
artiste vous les habitants et
professionnels en l'occurrence là je
dirais le milieu enseignant et des
équipes pédagogiques
on est un combat qui n'est pas normal de
manière comme ça alors ça devrait être
un droit
noah moi on n'est plus dans une logique
de réflexion et d'anticipation des
problèmes sur le territoire c'est à dire
que tout ce qu'on voit arriver on le
voit arriver en pleine face on voit que
les budgets qui centrait pour les écoles
va redescendre parc où va l'argent
parce que là on a quand même des
dysfonctionnements qui sont majeurs on
ne sait dire non
en sortant des bébés on y va des
illettrés on lit des parents et on
lâchera pas la peine et si rooney au mur
les choses enfin la route du bois allée
centrale aux déboires et on va vous
montrer ce qu'il faut un véritable
inventaire à la prévert de tous les
problèmes et donc ont signé et envoyé à
la mairie centrale sous forme de
questions écrites l'obligeront à
apporter une réponse
rien ne peut se faire sans la population
et la population ne peut rien faire sans
les élus je crois que c'est le fait
qu'on soit tous ensemble moi c'est ma
conception de la vie politique c'est que
c'est que les habitants sont avec nous
dans les combats que l'on même pour être
sûr de mener les vrais combats et les
bons combats
emporter l'adhésion des habitants dans
son combat c'est aussi l'objectif du
sénateur maire fn du secteur voisin dans
les 13e et 14e arrondissements
stéphane ravier fait donc la tournée des
écoles avec son équipe c'est fort
demandé à la victime s'était moqué au
prochain conseil municipal mais c'est
simplement évoqué il ya des études mais
a toujours rien de concret concernant
nos deux arrondissements donc là ils
sont en train de nous la faire comme on
est chez nous à l'envers il centrait
vers de l'enfumage sur le terrain devant
cette école qui ne disposent pas de
dortoir et qui en réclame 1 depuis des
années la pétition rencontre un franc
succès des marseillais comprennent bien
qu'il ne s'agit pas d'une démarche
politicienne et électoraliste
ac c'est rassembleur on va dire c'est
dans l'intérêt de tous les enfants quels
qu'ils soient
quelques quartiers qu'ils soient
et pour lui ça rassure les parents ce
qu'ils sont ils sont au courant de ce
qui se passe dans les écoles et dans
quel état sont les écoles de leurs
enfants
tout ce que nous souhaitons c'est que la
mairie centrale décentralise les moyens
et le personnel pour faire ces travaux
pour répondre aux attentes et dans les
meilleurs délais or la mairie centrale
est bien est une mairie qui centralise
tous et qui sclérosent doux depuis trop
d'années elle est coupée des réalités
une proposition inenvisageable pour la
mairie centrale
non à la mairie danièle casanova
adjointe chargée des écoles veut au
contraire montrer qu'on est loin d'être
inactif dont le 3e arrondissement par
exemple une nouvelle école a vu le jour
l'an dernier nous avons été obligés
d'offrir ce nouveau groupe scolaire très
rapidement et au groupe scolaire en dur
sa demande deux ans nos marchés publics
même trois quelque fois et il a fallu
que dans les six mois
on trouve des capacités d'accueil donc
on a construit cette école modulaire au
niveau de ce quartier des casernes
locaux climatisés matériel informatique
en quantité rétroprojecteur dans les
classes d'outiller une école qui a coûté
3 5 millions d'euros à la municipalité
de quoi désengorger un peu un secteur de
la ville saturée mais pour du temporaire
avec des préfabriqués
concrètement ces écoles elles peuvent
tenir combien de temps trop écouté elle
semble de toute façon ici il va y avoir
un nouveau quartier sur 150 hectares
avec trois écoles en dur mais en
attendant de réaliser ce nouveau
quartier sur qui va changer complètement
la halle ce site ici nous allons pouvoir
profiter au moins pendant une dizaine
d'années de ses classes en préfabriqué
face à la difficulté de trouver des
terrains la ville a aussi eu l'occasion
de récupérer un lycée dans le 4e
arrondissement jean claude gaudin
l'avait même inauguré en grande pompe à
la rentrée 2015 transformé pour des
jeunes écoliers il fait la fierté de la
municipalité et la mosaïque on a vendu
et gardez aussi je trouve que c'est très
c'est très beau on montre donc la mairie
bouche et après les premières réactions
de dénis sur la situation des écoles on
reconnaît désormais que oui des
dysfonctionnements existait bel et bien
et on tente d'y répondre
on va mettre un numéro vert qui sera
destiné exclusivement aux directeurs
d'école et ça sera le allô mairie
spécial écoles qui se chargera de
trouver le bon employé le bon service
qui vaudra qui viendra réparer le
problème de cas signalés directeur
d'école je crois que ça sera un gros
progrès parce que ça se perde elle est
numéro de téléphone
quelquefois les directeurs ne rejoignez
pas le bon numéro et la réaction n'était
pas aussi rapide que ce qu'on l'aurait
souhaité si la mairie a commencé à
réagir professeurs et directeurs
d'écoles restent mobilisés un collectif
tente de fédérer leurs revendications et
lance les états généraux de l'éducation
là aussi les témoignages affluent même
si les choses ont commencé à bouger dans
les écoles est apparemment dans tous les
sens mais après on arrive avec attention
au delà des moyens qui avait fait
revenir les choses et aussi des
fonctionnements améliorée moi ça fait 4
justement d'un organigramme précis des
services de la municipalité par exemple
le petit chose mais c'est très pratique
très concrète qui fait qu' on n'avance
pas je demande des accusés de réception
des mails je n'ai jamais aussi tout ça
pour dire que peut-être il faudrait se
poser la question du tout des relations
avec les directeurs sont quand même au
quotidien dont les sur lesquels on
compte la pénibilité
ça s'agite dans les écoles on reçoit des
tables qu'on avait commandé il ya trois
ans ou des choses comme ça on sent que
la mairie est un peu sous pression on
peut aussi face à chacune de nos
revendications mettre en face le texte
de loi laisse est constitutionnelle
voilà on demande pas la lune on ne
demande pas quelque chose d'incroyable
on demande le strict respect des lois
une liste de revendications et adopté
une première démarche avant d'autres
mobilisations à venir c'était une
première étape aujourd'hui qui était
intéressante de par la diversité des
personnes
tout est là qu elle soit du premier ou
du second degré aussi n'est pas la
diversité géographique puisque avait des
personnes qui venaient du centre de
marseille qui venaient de l'est du port
de marseille est donc cette première
base si vous voulez va essayer de faire
tache ville un petit peu pour continuer
à construire un rapport de force et pour
que vraiment soir mesure et de
contrainte les personnes qui nous oublie
face à cette agitation tous azimuts des
élus et des professeurs la mairie
consent finalement à faire des efforts
le conseil municipal du 1er avril est
donc l'occasion de passer au rattrapage
pour la ville des travaux sont votés et
des fonds supplémentaires débloqués
c'est le grand jean où c'est de
l'esbrouffe réputé ya ce qui va être
votée ensuite il ya la mise en oeuvre
donc
je prends acte de ce que va faire son
appel au maire de marseille je reconnais
donc il a fini par reconnaître que ce
que j'avais dit finalement j'avais
raison sur les écoles marseillaise et la
situation des écoles marseillaise
aujourd'hui les rapports qui vont passer
au conseil municipal
j'espère qu'ils seront suivies d'effet
dans les travaux passés vous savez c'est
quoi la première fois qu'on voit des
rapports passés pour autant au niveau
pas spécialement les travaux arrivent et
d'autres gestion financière
l'anc est ourdi par le snuipp et et
syndicats proches du parti de gauche a
été remise mercredi au service de l'état
malgré les appels réitérés et insistants
de ce syndicat auprès des enseignants
pour qu'ils dénoncent la moindre dalles
de plafond manquantes ou le col le
carreau soulevés dans les 3500 casse
marseillaise 187 écoles seulement sur
les 444 ont signalé 10 car quelques
dysfonctionnements soit 42%
chacun peut conclure que dans 58% des
écoles soit 257 64 444 les enseignants
sont satisfaits de l'état des locaux et
les actes ce sont les délibérations
d'aujourd'hui que vous nous présentez et
elle signe un terrible désaveu oui un
terrible désaveu pour le chef de votre
majorité
car alors que tout va bien madame la
marquise dans le meilleur des mondes on
dépêche en urgence des travaux ici et là
signe que finalement non tout ne va pas
bien il est certain
ici ou là sans doute il y avait des
travaux qui auraient dû peut-être être
fait qui de sang peut échapper
il aurait suffi aux il aurait suffi
qu'on nous le dise vieux de manière que
quand je le dis celui de manière peu
direct pour pouvoir effectivement
répondu nous l'avons fait immédiatement
nous avons dépêché des équipes qui ont
travaillé effectivement de manière très
forte pendant les vacances qu'ils
continueront à le faire d'ailleurs
pendant ces vacances de pâques nous
avons pris immédiatement un certain
nombre de décisions qui s'imposaient au
total mes chers collègues se 105
millions d'euros supplémentaires qui
seront alloués aux travaux dans les
écoles
l'enveloppé totale l'investissement pour
étant ainsi porter j'en remercie
l'adjoint aux finances bien entendu qui
a prévu tout cela de 36 millions d'euros
à 40 millions d'euros
et cet effort je le rappelle sera
reconduit en 2017 et 2018 5 millions
d'euros sur trois ans qui permettent
d'envisager des travaux d'urgence dans
les établissements les vacances d'avril
sont déjà l'occasion d'engager une
partie de ces fonds dédié aux écoles
si ce projet de rénovation étaient déjà
lancés avant la polémique
il illustre l'engagement de la ville
pour donc en résumé l'étanchéité des
toitures et s'est faite la semaine
dernière la dépose avec ses ça va vous
allez préfabriqués tout ça va où là
cette semaine il nous reste plus qu'à
terminer et les menuiseries l'isolation
thermique par l'extérieur plus les
bardages voilà nos priorités nous c'est
de finir donc les façades avant la
rentrée des classes
tout ce qu'il y ait une ovation karmique
la cage des salles qui prenait l'eau
sont donc rénové ici pour cent mille
euros et la rallonge budgétaire
permettra d'accélérer les chantiers ici
l'eau arrivait elle rentrer à
l'intérieur c'est ce qui me l'a tous
pourris donc il faut à tout prix quand
on puisse
certes c'était vieux mais aujourd'hui il
faut à tout plutôt soir puisque les
directives de monsieur le maire s'était
de démarrer ou plutôt nous ce genre de
choses bien sûr qu'on a on a la
possibilité de réagir assez vite
puisqu'on a des travaux qui sont
programmés puis à ceux qui ne le sont
pas qu'ils sont prévues pour les
suivantes donc parfois quand on a une
opportunité comme celle-là mais ça nous
permet d'avancer une programmation d'une
année sur des travaux engagés des fonds
débloqués ne manque plus que la grande
réconciliation entre le gouvernement et
la mairie
elle interviendra le 18 avril presque
main dans la main jean claude gaudin et
najat vallaud belkacem enterrent la
hache de guerre sur le terrain et après
les 5 millions d'euros par an de la
mairie c'est au tour de la ministre de
sortir le carnet de chèques
l'état a décidé de débloquer une
enveloppe de 5 millions d'euros au titre
des crédits de la politique de la ville
c'est une démarche qui se veut
exemplaire qui nous permet de sortir de
cette situation par le haut dans
laquelle l'état et la ville de marseille
travaille ensemble
au total ce sont donc 10 millions
supplémentaires par an qui sont
débloqués au vu du retard pris et du
nombre d'écoles a re construire ou à
rénover le chantier risque bien de
prendre des années et des années